Hello.
So welcome to the Polymer
State of the Union.
I'm not sure how familiar you
are with State of the Unions.
I'll try and make this
a lot more interesting.
But you may all--
like half of you
may have to stand
up and give standing
ovations like every
couple of minutes.
So I hope you warmed
up, did some squats,
that kind of thing.
Should be good.
So just a little bit about me.
My name is Matthew McNulty.
I lead the Polymer
team here at Google.
My Twitter handle is there.
It's mattsmcnulty.
Feel free to stalk me.
There's a lot of
young British women
who think I'm an
actor over there.
So they stalk me, and
they are similarly bored.
So feel free to join them.
For the sake of
this talk, I'm going
to assume that most of you
know something about Polymer,
as well as web components, and
you paid attention to Dimitri.
Just in case, I'm going to spend
just a minute or two talking
about what Polymer is.
Whoops, wrong button.
So Polymer a library that helps
you build elements and apps out
of web components.
So this sounds like a lot
of JavaScript frameworks
out there.
But Polymer is
different, in that it
uses web components, what
Dimitri was talking about,
this cutting edge
set of standards.
This lets it do less work
to achieve better results
than what came before, and
frees up framework authors
to concentrate on
making great apps.
So how great can apps be?
It turns out, with
Polymer, very great.
So it's easy to say,
but let's take a look.
So first, I'm going
to show you a mail app
that one engineer wrote
in just two weeks.
So granted, it was
Eric Beidleman.
He's pretty awesome.
But still, it was one
dev in just two weeks.
And I get to a demo on a
screen that's really far away.
All right.
So first off, let me make
this clear, this is not Gmail.
This is just a sample app
that we wrote in Polymer,
but it does is the
Gmail API and Google
sign in and
authentication-- which
I can sort of see my mouse.
And no one email me at
those other email addresses.
Forget you saw them.
So the Gmail API and in
the sign in authentication
API are just part of more
than 250 different APIs
that Google makes public.
So the Google Web
Components project,
which is a project we
started, turn those APIs
into web components.
It's at googlewebcomponents.org,
I believe.
Imagining some of these
APIs can be a pain,
but Web Components
reduces the boilerplate,
and makes it so they're
really simple to use
and really simple to integrate
into an app like this really
quickly.
So let me find my cursor again.
There it is.
So here we have an app
that's really, really
close to the native Gmail app.
You can see, if
I scroll it, it's
got a really cool
material design,
[INAUDIBLE] scroll thing.
I can also select items.
It's got some ink
effects there, undo it.
It's got an app drawer.
This stuff is pulling this
profile data from Google+.
It's profiling the tags.
It's pulling the tags
from the Gmail API.
This is all a real
app with real data.
And it's even responsive.
I can bring it really big
and it adjusts automatically.
It still has all the
really cool effects.
So anyway, you can
swipe messages,
you can do swipe to delete.
Undo it.
And it all just
works really well.
And this just uses the web
platform, uses Web Components
and uses Polymer.
Let me get back here.
All right.
So now we see what we can do
with Polymer and part of what
makes it different.
But let's dig into it
just a little bit more
and see what makes it unique.
So we make a big
deal out of the fact
that Polymer is a library
and not a framework.
This goes back to
using Web Components
and really using the platform.
So a long time ago, web apps
are written in HTML and using
built-in tags, like
button and form.
So Polymer returns
to that world,
but this time with
custom elements.
And with Polymer,
developers write HTML,
but the framework is DOM.
We don't build our
own framework on top.
Polymer is just a
really thin layer
on top of that new and
improved web platform.
So that's created
at a high level,
but what does it actually do?
So the first thing it does is
it sugars the primitives that
make up web components.
So why does this new
hotness that Dimitri just
danced around and talked
about need sugaring?
It's because, like
all good primitives,
web components are
really low level.
And that makes them really
flexible and really powerful,
but not quite as
easy as they can be.
And Polymer helps that out.
So Polymer also
reduces boilerplate,
keeping your code
limited to just
what's unique in
your application.
And it adds a declarative
syntax to Web Components.
This is in the
spec, but no one's
implemented it yet,
including Chrome.
And this allows you
to develop in markup,
which makes it really simple.
And most importantly,
Polymer has an opinion.
It's how we think elements
and applications built
with Web Components
should be built.
So here's Dimitri again.
This is an actual picture of
him working on Web Components.
I definitely didn't
Photoshop this yesterday.
It's definitely
not my wallpaper.
So this is just a
little history lesson.
The state of the
art, for a long time,
has been JavaScript developers
building their own platforms
on top of the web,
because the web
platform wasn't good enough.
But now with Web
Components, it is.
And Polymer is the
next step in that story
that Dimitri was
telling earlier.
It's the experiment to prove
that Web Components are
awesome, to use his term.
So experiments have results.
How have we been doing?
So Polymer has a lot of
really great features
for making building
web apps easier.
So developers love them.
We've had a million unique
visitors to Polymer.
We're in the midst of holding
a bunch of education events
around the world,
called Polytechnics.
119 of them so far.
And 85% of the
participants say they're
going to use Polymer
in the next project.
So in our little report card
here, I'm completely biased,
but I think we get
an A for that one.
So grading yourself is
the best kind of grading,
in case you don't know that.
So how about productivity?
So Polymer lets developers
build applications
faster and with less code.
So Quickoffice is
a user of Polymer.
And they removed
10,000 lines of code
when they moved to Polymer
for their document rendering.
And again, the Mail app I
showed earlier, written by Eric,
came from one
developer in two weeks,
to build a really polished,
really nice web app.
So let's give that
one another biased A.
We've also got a lot of
elements the developers can
use as is for their apps.
You saw some of those
in the Gmail app.
These are built with Polymer,
but they're not Polymer.
They're a separate thing.
We have a few different sets.
We have core elements,
we have paper elements
for functional and UI elements.
And we expect there to
be a lot more of these.
And you saw, paper elements are
our material design elements.
And material design was this
really awesome effort inside
of Google, because the Polymer
team, the Android team,
and the team that works on
the iOS framework for iOS apps
at Google, all worked
together side by side
on the same project.
It was equal partners
across it all.
So as you can see from
the demo I did earlier,
developers can build awesome
experiences with these.
So working on
perfect GPA so far.
Mom's going to be really proud.
So how about performance?
So Topeka, this really cool quiz
app we showed earlier at I/O,
the Polymer Mail app
I was just showing,
and our sample apps work great.
But to be honest,
performance is inconsistent.
The things take tuning.
And they're especially
inconsistent on browsers
that don't yet support native
web components, like Safari.
So developers have told
us that mobile Safari is
super important for the mobile
web, they can't just ignore it.
But getting quality
performance on that browser
is really challenging.
So there's our perfect GPA.
So I'm going to give that
a "Needs Improvement."
Mom's going to be pretty mad.
But we're progressive optimists
here on the Polymer team,
so we're going to rephrase
that to "Maximum Improvement
Opportunity."
I was going to do an
acorn, because it's
the furthest from
a tree, but that
was going to get a
little too weird.
So how about payload
and complexity?
So these things go
together really often.
So Polymer itself
is pretty lean.
It's 123K, it's a 66K gzipped.
For an app in like a
fully featured framework,
that's pretty great.
But for a single element, which
is what Web Component says
you can mix and match on
the page, not so much.
And Polymer is supposed to
be able to do less, which
means it should be
smaller, because it's
built on Web Components.
And in terms of complexity,
Polymer is pretty complex.
It can be difficult to
know what's going on,
if you want to look
under the surface
and see what's happening.
And again, for an
app, that's OK.
But for mixing and matching
all these different elements
from different
vendors, not as much.
So I think we have to
admit we have another
"Maximum Opportunity
for Improvement" here.
So let's look at the
whole report card.
So ergonomics, productivity,
and expressiveness are A's.
A for awesome, as
Dimitri would say.
And performance and payload
need some improvement.
So this illustrates an
issue we've had all along.
Polymer has dueling goals.
Be this experiment that pushes
the platform forward and lives
on the edge, but also be
something production worthy
that developers can depend on.
So we've done a great job with
at former, note all those A's.
But the latter is clearly
a work in progress.
But the experiment's over now.
Native features are
shipped in Chrome.
Polymer is fully feature
enough to build apps,
like I showed you.
And we started out with
no native features at all
when we started this project
two years ago, and almost
no knowledge about how all
this stuff would work together.
And now that's changed.
So now it's time to make
Polymer production ready.
So in the last
month, we've begun
to take a hard look at
every aspect of Polymer.
So we've learned a
ton we can put use
to making Polymer better.
We looked at each
and every feature
and tried to hammer it down into
a leaner, less complex shape,
without sacrificing the really
great features that everyone
loves.
So we made a bunch
of improvements
and we're ready to tell
you about them today.
So first, we've
refactored Polymer
into a series of layers.
So core features are really
fast and really lean.
Advanced features that are
more costly are opt-in.
And we strived for
the 80/20 Rule.
So try to accommodate
all the common use cases
and let the rest opt-in
to more advanced features.
So that's the first change.
Another change is we've greatly
simplified our data binding
system.
So like everything
else, we've optimized it
for performance and simplicity.
So most properties don't
require two-way binding,
so we've made that opt-in.
So if you think of
an Ajax request,
there's a zillion things you
can set, but really only one
response that you want
to actually listen to.
So we've made that opt-in.
Polymer has always had
implicit types for properties,
but we've made
that explicit now.
And change notification uses
events for interoperability
across elements from
different frameworks.
And another thing we're
doing is specifically
geared up browsers that
have not implemented
Shadow DOM and the
rest of Web Components.
So this change is specific
to them and not Chrome.
So we have a Shadow DOM
Polyfill, it's awesome.
It's this feat of engineering.
It's spec compliant, but
it's also pretty intrusive.
And because it's a pretty
big feature, it's pretty big.
So instead, we're going to
take the tack of building
a shim-style layer that just
polyfills what Polymer needs.
And the existing
polyfill is going
to live on for generic
non-Polymer Web Component's
code, and that's
the third change.
So those are the
high level changes,
but what are the
results of this effort?
So it's still pretty early.
Performance testing is
a really tricky art.
But we have some
results to share.
So the first thing we
tested was startup time.
So how long we can go
from launch until the app
is ready to use.
So first on Chrome.
So I've always wanted
an excuse to use that.
[APPLAUSE]
So like a medium complexity app
starts about five times faster
on Chrome than it was before.
So that's a huge speedup.
On Safari, the story is
a little bit different.
So the same steps starts up
eight times faster on Safari.
So that's more of an
improvement than Chrome,
but we have more
to do on Safari.
So Chrome is still
faster, because it
has the native features.
But the penalty is reduced to
as small as we could make it.
All right, so it's
way faster, but what
about payload and complexity?
So we've reduced payload
87%, so it's 15K now.
And that's 6K gzipped.
[APPLAUSE]
And this is with the same
features and the same use
cases.
So we're not quite done.
These numbers are going
to change a little bit.
My team wants me
to emphasize that.
But you can get an
idea, about now,
about how we sped
things up so much.
We went really, really
simple and down to the metal.
And so, to be honest,
it surprised even us
that we could do this
without a major disruption
to the feature set.
But it's fun and easy
to say these things.
So let's look at
actual evidence.
Let's go to the videotape.
So this is showing Pica,
which is a newsreader demo.
It kind of does
RSS feed reading,
which we've had for
a really long time.
And we've got two versions
of it running on a Nexus 9.
On the left, you've
got the new Polymer.
On the right, we've got
the existing Polymer.
It's the same app.
So that actually went
early, didn't it?
So let's see the difference.
Bling, bloop.
[APPLAUSE]
So here's the same
thing on an iPad Air.
[APPLAUSE]
It gets better.
So here's a synthetic test.
This is like a medium complexity
list, a lot a list data
and a lot of data, actually,
here on our Nexus 9.
And now here's the
same thing on an iPad.
And, no, it didn't freeze.
All right.
So let's take a look at
our report card again.
So we stayed after
school, we worked hard.
And Mom's much happier now.
We've improved precisely
where we've needed it,
and we haven't touched the
features that developers love.
Of course, nothing like is free.
So there are some breaking
changes, especially when
it comes to data binding
in certain cases.
But it's really not that scary.
It will not require a rewrite.
So elements might
not have to change
at all, individual
elements you've made.
Larger apps might need a
few days to a week to adapt,
but it kind of
depends on the app.
Some apps may not have
to change really, at all.
So basically, about a few
minor version numbers worth of
changes, but all at once.
So to make sure people
realize that, we're
changing the version
number to 0.8,
both to show they
were closer to 1.0
and we're 0.3
better than before.
[LAUGHTER]
Glad people got sort of
"Spinal Tap" reference there.
So I've got a few other
things to talk about, too.
We've covered what
Polymer is already,
and I do that every single talk.
And all of us do that every
single talk, and people still
get really confused
about it-- even people
that work on Web Components.
So Polymer web components
are pretty big, new things.
And some people think Polymer
is just the polyfills.
Some people think Polymer is
the material design elements.
We'd kind of like
to clear that up.
So the polyfills that
Polymer uses are agnostic.
They work with
any other library.
Brick uses them today.
These are Web
Components polyfills,
not Polymer polyfills, and
they're generally useful.
These polyfills are not Polymer.
We wrote them, but they're
not part of Polymer itself.
So we're going to move
them away from Polymer
into webcomponents.org
so other library authors
or developers can use them
without any confusion at all.
And the community can improve
them independent of Polymer.
So we wrote them, but
we want everyone else
to be able to use them until
the day we can happily get rid
of them, because everyone
supports Web Components.
So elements, they're
made with Polymer,
but like I said before,
they're not Polymer.
Polymer is a material
design, but we
make a set of material
design elements.
So we're going to
take them, we're
going to move them to their
own part of the website.
And I think we're
eventually going
to give them their own identity
and put them somewhere else.
But for right now, they're kind
of separated out from Polymer.
And what's left is
the core of Polymer,
that 15K, or that 6K gzipped.
And now that core
is production-track.
So that means no
more fuzzy labels
that mean nothing,
an actual roadmap.
That's still a little fuzzy.
So 0.8 is in preview today.
So it's live today as a
branch of Polymer, itself.
It's still really,
really, early.
It lacks docs, like completely.
It's still missing a
couple of features.
But you can take a
look, if you're brave.
We like to do
everything in public,
so we've got it sitting there.
0.9 we're going to call "beta,"
it will be early next year.
And then 1.0 really
soon after that.
So the idea is, we're focused
on the core of Polymer,
and we're going to put it out
in production as quickly as we
can.
So even as an experiment,
until now, lots of people
are actually using Polymer.
So we love early adopters
out there on the front lines
of the web platform with us.
And I have a bunch of
them I'd like to show you.
So first up is Salesforce.
Salesforce is Polymer's BFF.
So they're here somewhere.
They really, really get Polymer.
They've gotten Polymer from the
first time we put it out there.
They're the people I
bring to the office
every time the team
needs a pick-me-up.
And their mobile SDK
teams built this whole SDK
for their developers
to use Polymer
to build Salesforce apps.
So they built a
whole SDK on Polymer,
and they're shipping
that to their customers.
And they've also built a
reference hybrid application
that runs across
multiple platforms
and has secure offline storage.
And it uses Polymer,
as you can see here.
So this is actually a product
that they shipped this week,
and blogged about,
I think, yesterday.
So next up News Corp. News
Corp has this awesome team
using Polymer to experiment
with next-gen tools
for understanding, manipulating
data with components,
and putting that data in
the hands of journalists.
This is really,
really cool stuff,
and it's at the cutting edge
of data-driven journalism.
And now for some
Google products.
So YouTube is using Polymer.
So for some users, this
is going live this week.
It's going to be
the Related Videos
list to one side for
a percentage users
they're going to get,
will be moved over
to Polymer this week.
So Quickoffice, I
mentioned before, they've
got a rewrite coming of
their whole renderer.
This uses Polymer, it's
shipping very, very soon.
And it Radically
simplified their code base.
So 10,000 fewer lines of
code to do the same thing.
So Translate is also
developing their user interface
in Polymer.
And you may not realize
this, but hundreds
of millions of people use
translate every single day.
Google Play Music is
also using Polymer.
And Santa Tracker.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm actually happy that
got the most applause.
So this is a great story.
So I don't know if
you guys know this.
1955, a Sears store
in Colorado Springs
put an ad in the
paper saying kids
could call and talk to Santa.
And they put the
wrong number in,
and they actually put the
precursor to NORAD's number in.
So this colonel in NORAD
in Colorado Springs
started getting phone
calls on Christmas
asking where Santa was.
And this colonel
actually happens
to be the grandfather
of a good friend of mine
who works at Google.
And he started to
just actually give out
where Santa is to all the kids.
And a tradition was born.
So it's a really cool story.
You should look into it.
So the Santa Tracker
that's going to-- this
is the current one--
the Santa Tracker that's
going to launch this
upcoming season uses Polymer.
And its awesome.
And for all your
Santa stalking needs.
So there's a whole lot
more users of Polymer
inside of Google.
Really, too many
to actually list,
but there's a whole bunch more.
So let's wrap up.
So that was a lot of new stuff.
So in summary, so the next
major version of Polymer
is coming shortly.
It's out today.
It's super, super fast, super,
super light, and really,
really, modular.
And it's going to require really
minimal changes for developers
to adapt to.
Everything you're doing
today still works.
And Polymer is no
longer an experiment.
So, hurray, it's a
production-track.
[APPLAUSE]
And the polyfills are moving
over to webcomponents.org.
That's already happening today.
And lots of people are already
using Polymer, including Santa,
and you should join them.
Rob's up next.
He's going to dive
in a lot deeper.
And so you can do
nothing, and Rob's
going to be here in a minute,
you don't even have to move.
You can do something,
and follow us on polymer.
And we're on GitHub.
The name of the GitHub
project is Polymer.
And come check us out, build
a project, and join the fun.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]